I told you yesterday that Corona virus is
spiking in many parts of the country.
And we also talked on the bonus show, I guess
it was it was either two days ago or six months
ago.
I don't know.
Everything feels the same.
Know sometime this week about how Donald Trump
has decided that it is time to restart huge
campaign rallies, massive crowds gathered
together, spreading the virus, yelling about
how great Donald Trump is.
And now even more cartoonishly, Donald Trump's
first rally is going to be in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
on June 19th.
Also known as Juneteenth, which Trump is combining
a location that was the site of a massive
racist massacre with a very important day.
June 19th is the anniversary of the emancipation,
the freeing of the last enslaved African-Americans
in the Confederacy.
Confederacy.
Somehow it's 20 20.
But a big topic this week, Tulsa in 1921 was
the location of a huge racist massacre where
mobs of white people destroyed a predominantly
black dress district called Greenwood, which
was called Black Wall Street.
And there are a number of different questions
here.
One is, how calculated is the date and location
Juneteenth in Tulsa, Oklahoma, by Donald Trump?
I think Trump probably knows very, very little
about this history, but certainly people like
Steven Miller and others around Trump probably
know more about this history.
And to some degree, I think they get off on
doing this type of stuff.
Now, the broader public health question is,
why is this happening in Oklahoma at all?
And the reason is that Oklahoma starting to
allow large events as part of their corona
virus reopening.
Do the numbers support this decision in Oklahoma?
Not really.
I mean, if you look at the data, we're looking
at case numbers.
Oklahoma is not hugely spiking.
It's not really improving, though.
They have had a pretty steady trickle of cases
for the last three months.
But since the
start of June, Oklahoma has had its highest
three day average of cases.
It is difficult to imagine any way that a
huge rally, if masks are not required, is
not going to lead to a spike in cases.
Now, it might not be huge, but there's going
to be more contagion because of a huge rally
like this.
But it just doesn't matter to the president
or to the administration or to his campaign.
They've decided, as a practical matter, that
corona virus is over.
It's time to rally.
That's it.
There's no more press briefings.
There's barely any discussion of corona virus.
They don't talk about deaths.
They don't talk about cases other than to
lie and say how great they are.
Now, it is not just Tulsa, Oklahoma, that
Donald Trump will be going to Donald Trump
will be holding rallies in Florida, Arizona
and North Carolina.
And those are not.
Maybe it's OK.
Maybe it's not.
Those are epicenters of disease right now.
You have to see this to believe it.
These are case growth curves that absolutely
do not suggest that you should be having huge
rallies in these states, especially with people.
Remember, right wingers are much more likely
than left wingers not to take the virus seriously,
not to stay home, not to wear masks, not to
do the things we need to do to prevent spreading
it.
And by that, we are likely to see even more
spread.
So in North Carolina, cases have been steadily
increasing and rising.
North Carolina does not appear to have peaked
yet.
It's getting worse and worse and worse in
North Carolina as the days go by.
Florida, as I told you yesterday, had a dip
in cases in late April, but that might have
been when they were just
lying about the numbers.
They have again peaked with new record case
numbers coming in the first part of June so
far.
That's not where you want to be doing huge
rallies.
And then you've got Arizona, Arizona, maybe
with the worst trend line of any of these
states.
Cases were sort of low in Arizona, four months
slow increase.
And since the start of June, just a massive
spike to cases in Arizona.
Arizona is close to one of the worst places
in the country where you should be having
a mass rally.
They're in danger of running out of ICU beds
all of a sudden.
And that's where Donald Trump wants to go.
I spoke to a friend who lives in Arizona this
morning, told me that no one's wearing masks
unless it's absolutely required and that it's
not really required almost anywhere, even
most indoor places.
And
the nursing homes are having a real, real
issue.
In Arizona, it's almost like Trump's choosing
the worse places.
And this could work to get Corona virus to
some rural communities.
We've been talking a lot about, you know,
Corona virus has been centered around cities
because that's where you have more people.
Cities tend to have more direct flights to
China and to Europe.
That made it early epicenters.
We're likely going to be in cities, rural
folks.
We'll come to Tulsa, Oklahoma.
They'll come to Phenix or wherever, and then
they'll bring the virus back out to rural
areas.
People there will get the virus.
But those rural areas have a far lower hospital
capacity and dramatically lower ICU capacity.
And you can imagine the way it's all going
to go.
Now, meanwhile, just to show you that things
can be handled properly.
Take a look at Switzerland's curve.
Switzerland has had under one hundred new
cases per day since five weeks ago.
Very few deaths.
It's just one example.
It can be done.
Look at look at Iceland.
Look at.
There's so many different examples.
We'll get, of course, Taiwan up.
But you really need competent leadership.
You need fewer really dumb people.
And unfortunately, here in the United States,
we lack leadership.
And I mean, let's face it, we have a lot of
ignorance.
We have a lot of ignorance.
And that is a bad combination.
I want to remind you that Tuesday we are doing
something nice to build community.
So much news is negative these days.
We are having the second David Pakman show
chess tournament.
I will be playing in the tournament.
I want you to play in it all skill levels
or welcome.
It's free.
This is just totally free.
We're just running this for community sake.
It will be on the Web site.
Lead chess dawg.
That's Ally Chess start.
Oh ah g.
You can sign up on the Web site.
Now I will be tweeting out the link to the
tournament, probably seven forty five p.m.
Eastern on Tuesday the 16th.
The tournament will start at eight and it
will run somewhere around 75 to 90 minutes.
So make sure you are.
I hope you participate.
We had 500 people play last time.
I would love to double it if possible.
Also, remember, you can follow me on Twitter
at David Pakman, at the Pacman, on Twitter.
And remember, if you tend to watch YouTube
clips, but you want to get a daily podcast,
there's the free daily podcast of The David
Pakman Show one hour long.
It's on iTunes, Spotify, Pandora, Google Play,
Stitcher, all of these different places.
You
can get
it there.